I thought I saw that again I'm remind
[Music]
sorry your father's gone at some point
we have to face up to who we are who
were meant to be I think I know where my
dad went that's right in the middle of
the devil sea it would be an adventure
adventure what are you doing here Laura
seven years I've been on this island
your father they put me here now I see
the likeness intelligence
so recklessness
what do you know about my father Laura
there was more to my life than
boardrooms and business deals there's an
organization called Trinity it's looking
to start a global genocide you dare June
you have a bigger holiday got a knack
for the unexpected
you must stop for Laura
promise me
[Music]
ladies first
open the tomb
don't your fingers pulling this trigger
you messed with the wrong family
[Music]
listen is very simple if you don't sign
the papers then everything your father
worked for will be sold off not just the
company the Croft Manor also can you
imagine how you would feel if you lost
the house
sorry your father's gone but you could
pick up where he left off
it's in your blood I'm sorry I'm just
not that kind of Croft
that was Stan's yes miss Croft
according to Richards will in the event
of his death I was to give it to you
karakuri Japanese puzzle and technically
speaking that you meant to sign the
papers first
I would never understand your father's
obsession with those things wouldn't
believe how many of these were lying
around the house
there was gonna be some purpose
[Music]
I first flesh up for my final
destination but you didn't leave a
letter
[Music]
hello sprout I knew I could trust you to
solve my puzzle unfortunately if you're
watching this tape then it means that I
must be dead it'll be obvious to you by
now that there was more to my life than
just boardrooms and business deals
things that I couldn't tell you about
before I need you to do me a favor
I need you to burn all my research on
the Himiko project just burn all of it
the notebooks that tapes everything it's
very important if it falls into the
wrong hands then it could be
catastrophic so please do it straight
away I know you hate being told what to
do but please promise me that I hope you
never have to see this tape but if you
do you found my secret calling I think I
know where they went I danced to the
bottom of the sea they were headed to an
uninhabited island so off the coast of
Japan used to be called hammer time
there's at least six thousand islands
off the coast of Japan hardly any of
them are populated well I have a map now
all I need to do is to figure out what
these are I think these are coordinates
the location
their clock hands knock clock hands
that's the one that's right in the
middle of the devil see you might as
well tie stone to your foot and chop off
the bow now it'll be an adventure death
is not an adventure
let's go
La Crosse you shouldn't have come here
I'm glad that you did pack it up we're
moving camp
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you really want to give this little girl
let's just go home
I was quite young there was only eight I
remember my dad's friends children had a
Playstation I remember when they played
Lara Croft
I haven't seen a girl in the lead
character in a video game she was
extremely fierce and determined capable
and epic adventurer
I've been dreaming since I was a kid be
part in big action adventure to push
myself and in this film I really came to
do
[Music]
all story it's very much an origin story
surname Croft little beginning she's a
regular girl living in East London
here's the part since she's seen her dad
so she goes out an adventure to see if
he's still out there
you shouldn't have come here I'm glad
that you did this film is about her
becoming the action here that we know
her to be when it comes to the action
Alicia as a beast you have to see her in
this movie man she's just a winning
combination you know she's been training
her Fight Club while work water work
shootouts chases it's relentless I was
amazed by what she went through she gets
beaten up all day long
bruises and the hips you can adjust suck
up but the cold that is the tough thing
when you reach hypothermia level do we
have water Catherines being thrown at us
we fly right in the middle of them we've
even had to reshoot some things because
they turn to blue and it can't fix that
on-screen apparently I wanted her to be
a strong physical girl so I started to
gain muscle
strength she's just a real powerhouse
she made me embarrassed to take my shirt
off and I go to the gym five days a week
it's been a very physical adventure
Alisha has impressed me a lot
this first time we've seen her lead an
action movie and she's taken this bull
by the horn a lot of passion for
adventure that's it
but she stands up again
gonna have the big sets and the mystical
doors being open always wanted to try
all these mystical action beats I feel
like I have the strength to do it
what's your name Laura surname Croft
Laura your father's gone you could pick
up where he left off I see so much of
him in you
brilliant hello sprout if you're
listening to this then I must be dead
I found something a tune called the
mother of death if Trinity succeeds our
world is in danger promise me you will
stop I promise I think I know where my
dad went that's right in the middle of
the devil sea it will be an adventure
death isn't 100 an adventure
[Music]
you shouldn't have come here but I'm
glad that you did
[Music]
14 about my father
now I see the lightness the recklessness
close the to once and for the fate of
humanity is now in your hands
[Music]
don't be too careful these days the
world has gone bloody mad I'll take two
[Music]